you choreographed a YouTube video that
went viral receiving 4 million views in
2016. you were 15.
the one for Beyonce Run the World and
that one was just about women
empowerment and that was one of my
favorite ones just the message behind it
and it just we went to sleep and I swear
it was like we woke up and there was
like three million views and we were
like
wait what like did Beyonce call you or
message you she posted us on Twitter
and like put up our video and I think
that's how that one kind of sparked she
loved it she sent it out and boom yeah
and that started getting you some
attention yeah and that's kind of and
you're dancing I need to watch this we
need to go watch this yeah are you are
you great in this
is it pretty cool I yeah you should
watch it